What are the actions you
would tell me to take?
What are the things you
would tell me to do?
>> There's like eating the dots.
>> Yeah like that.
So that seems like a reasonable
thing to do eat dot.
>> I guess the little dots versus
the big dots they might be two different
things because I want to eat a big
dot if I want to turn the tables on
the ghosts and pursue them.
>> Right, okay, so,
I'll just call the little dot dot.
>> Okay.
And then I feel like it's really
important to have a strategy for
escaping from the ghosts or pursuing
the ghost depending on the mode.
>> Okay, so, yeah so,
you might want to eat a ghost and
you might want to avoid a ghost.
Anything else?
>> I mean I guess we could come up
with more detailed strategy ideas but
those feel like the basic things.
>> Yeah I think that
pretty much covers it.
And if you were, when we go back and
we listen to the recording later Michael
I think you'll find that this is almost
exactly what you said when you
explained how the game worked.
You said you need to
eat the little dots.
And you also have to eat the big dots
eventually because you need to clear.
If the ghost touch you then you die,
so you need to avoid the ghosts.
But if you eat the big dots then
you can actually eat the ghosts.
And that's pretty much how
you describe the game.
>> I see, so,
the way that I kind of thought about the
game to convey it to people, is at this
sort of high level that kind of makes
sense with respect to options as well.
>> Right, which is what I also think was
true in the in the other grid world.
Now, we could look at this and
we say well these are options and
maybe we can learn these options, or
they're given to us and somebody could
code them up for us, I don't know.
I want to point out a couple of
things about these options though and
this is going to bring us back
to your excellent analogy.
About programming and about computing.
Which is if we think of these things
as functions or procedures to execute.
Which I think is a perfectly
reasonable thing to do.
I want to point out that
what we get from functions,
procedures is not just the ability
to reason at a high level.
But we also get something
called separation of concerns.
Which allows us to only think
about parts of the world.
So for example if you want
me to multiply two numbers.
I only have to worry
about those two numbers.
I don't have to worry about
the state of the stack or
whatever else is going
on in this program.
I just need to worry about the two
numbers you're asking me to multiply.
So there's a similar kind of
gain in abstraction that you get
here by picking options carefully.
So, to illustrate this I'm going to
ask you to do one more thing.
I want you to tell me,
what are the states of this world?
What are the features that
make up the states in Pac-Man?
Okay so there's,
well it's definitely different
if there's any dots left
versus there's no dots left.
>> Right, so-
>> That's an important distinction.
>> So the dots and
where they are on the screen matter.
So there's-
>> You want,
okay so not an abstraction of the state.
You actually want literally
the things that make up the state.
>> Well which I claim as an abstraction
of the state, almost by definition.
So, I think what you said before
works in either case, right?
So there're dots,
there're dots on the screen.
I need to know where all the dots are,
and so there's some set of features,
the make of the state that
tell me where dots are.
>> Right, okay, so
then there's where the Pac-Man is.
The location of the little dots,
location of the big dots,
location of the Pac-Man,
location of the ghosts.
And I guess the walls aren't
really part of the state.
In the sense that they
don't really change.
Though I guess if we were talking about
multiple levels of the game we might
have to also say where the walls are.
>> True, I'm going to claim that you
don't have to do that because it's all
going to be taken care of by the, you
could and there's nothing wrong with it.
But it's actually all going to be taken
care of by the transition function.
Right there's, you can't enter wall.
So you can't from a state go
into where a wall happens to be.
>> Okay, and whether the ghosts are in,
I don't know what to call it,
but power pellet mode.
Whether the ghosts are fleeing from us,
or whether they're attacking us.
>> Right, so
we talk about scared ghosts.
>> Scared,
whether the ghosts are scared, I see.
They always look a little
scared with their bulging eyes.
>> Right.
Not when they're coming
after you they don't.
But when they start blinking purple and
they're running away from you and
screaming, aah!
Then they seem a little scared to me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Maybe that's just my
version of Pac-Man.
Anyway.
So here's a bunch of features.
And the details here matter
in implementation, but
I think for
what we're talking about don't, right?
And we talk about where the dots are.
It doesn't have to be
where the dots are,
it could be where
the closest dot is to you.
Or where the farthest dot is to you,
or it could be every single dot and
whether it's on or off.
Same true for the big dots.
Pac-Man, you have to
know where Pac-Man is.
You need to know where ghosts are maybe
just need to care about where the closes
ghost is whatever.
It does matter whether they're scared or
not.
In the same way that we don't have
to keep track of the walls or
other things here we might
not have to keep track of.
But, whatever it is we're going to do in
the detail I think to solve the game,
I think your reasoning is right.
You need to know where the dots are of
various flavors we need to know where
the ghost and
where we are and we need to know
whether we can eat the ghost or not.
And these features however they're
exactly expressed, are important for
solving and planning in the game.
Now, here's the observation
I'm going to make,
just like when I ask you to multiply two
numbers I don't need to know everything
else that's going on in your program.
I suspect that is the case that,
even though I need all of these features
to effectively and
efficiently solve a Pac-Man board.
My options do not necessarily
need to know all of these things.
So, for example if you
told me to avoid the ghost
ask yourself whether it matters
whether the ghosts are scared or not.
>> [LAUGH] Interesting, okay.
Yeah, I guess if I'm if I
am avoiding the ghosts.
Well, yeah, it changes their behavior,
so it may depend on that, sure.
>> Right, so I think we should delve
into this a little more deeply.
And the way I want to
do that is with a quiz.